E
WHERE ABORTIG TO BE
ALL BUIMATTAIN I THI TOWARD A
>>T TO RED ALEITICTH MAKES NO R
TUTIONAL PROVISION
E ONESE ELY.YINGS NO
THEREFORE IDOES.
THAT HAS IMPLICATIONS FOR
EVEN HE HINTS R OF RIG
THOSE RIGHTS AREN'T ON THE  BLO
THE SUEMAFTER OR AT LEAST ADDREE
FRAMEWORK THAT WOULD STRIKE THE.
INRIGHT NOW
JUSTICES KAVANAU AND RER
R COREWE'RE NOT GOIN GL THE
Y AT MEANS WE'RE ONETICE  IONO I
WHATEVER ELSEUPE
TODAAN THERE WAS YESTERDAY,
D  OF RI  WEST HERE ON Y ER
QUESTIONS.
>> YOU SAY THE WILWE
AND I WANT T SNIDER
ENCE THOMAS SPEAKS VERY
AIN LANGUAGE ABOUT THIS,
RIGHT?
>> RIGHT.
AND WHAT'S INTERESTINGJOHN,
THIS OPINION IS BUE NG A THREE
OE OPINIONLD
AFFECT OTHER
THIS COUNTRY TAKE FOTED
TCONCEPTION AND
THE RIGHTO SAME SEX MARRIAGE
ESTA THIS COURT.
DECISION W FR ALITO
NOT MISUNDETO OR
MISCHARACTERIZED WE EMPHASIZE IT
COL
RIGHT TO ABORTION D GHT.
NOTHING IN THIS OPINION SHOULD
BE UNDERSTOOD TO CAST DOUBT IN
PRECEDENHA NOT CONCERN
ABORTION.
AND JUSTICE BRETT KAVANAUGH ALSO
HOWEVER YOU NOTED JUSTICE
CLARENCEHOWAS QUITE BLUN HE WAN.
AND HERE'S THETE FOR HIM.
PRECEDENTS INCLUDINGHOULD  ALL
LAWRENCE
WE'RE SEEING THII
JUSTICE THOMAS MAYBE WANTING TO
GOUCH FURTHER THANOM
SEX MARR, E ED TLEE
GH CONTRACEPTION RT OR TOMORROW?
A YEAR OR TWO BEFE THE
SUPRE N, OBVUS
RED ST GHESEE THAT WSTATES, NAMY
PRECEDENTS.
THERE ARE LEGISLATORS INMISSISSR
EXAMPLE.
WELL, I
REONHICH IS THAT THE ANALY
THE NO TT RIGHTS UNLESS
TRUDERISIONS THAS MITED
RED O
STATES MOVING QUICKL TO
PUNVERT.O I WANT T
T  CHIEFERTSWHO SAID I WOULD TA
JOHNE MEASURED
COURSE, I  THE COURT Y OF LINR
AND E GOG A
PROGRAIS.
BUT IS I TO SA THAN
THE EE S MITCH L'Y BECAUSE IF
E COAND YOU WOULD NOHAVE 5-3.
ETT.CKEDEDY
THAT IS WHAT'S SUENTIA
AND CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTEEN AT
HIS POWECOHEST DOESN'TE ITVE JUF
N THATTHREE OF s.
COCONCUREDD
BUT THIS IA WHOLE NECOAND IT REO
REASON.
CLCE INFORCE WHAT JUSTIE
GNGARATTLE E RIGHT TOTRVE NOT .
THEY SHOULD BELLENGED.
>> TO BES OT JUST N THE
SUEME COURT.TWO YEAMT NO
APPELLATE JUDGESIRMED.EW JUDGES
MITCH McCONNELL AN
DID QUITE
SUCCESSFULLY AT SHIFNGHEN T.
, YES, THEE THREE VERY
EME COUR
STSIDENCY, B